got kind of a mix of clouds and sunshine
out there as we take a look out across
the valley this morning it is a little
breezy but it's not downright windy yet
we expect that we will get some winds
going again today as a cold front kind
of moves through the area we've had a
lot of neighborhoods that didn't get out
of the 80s overnight so some 70s though
mountains edge centennial hills aliante
mid 70s out at red rock it is going to
be windy by the afternoon so if you want
to do some hiking be outdoors maybe try
to get your outdoor stuff done this
morning and then you'll be free this
afternoon so you're not out there trying
to fight the winds mid 70s in boulder
city 78 indian springs 77 in mesquite 81
in laughlin and up in caligani it's 56
61 in tona pal look at death valley 92
and got more triple digits coming for
death valley as you might expect and we
have low triple digits too coming from
the valley today before we really start
cooling down over the weekend 74 up on
the mountain and look for those gusty
winds up there today and some rough
waters out at lake mead white caps with
the winds up 30 miles an hour could be
even stronger at times 103 clouds and
sunshine through the morning and then i
think the afternoon will bring us some
better sunshine breezy to gusty through
monday
as a couple of systems move through hot
temperatures today and then again later
next week but between today and late
next week much cooler 80s arriving by
memorial day and tuesday
maybe even sunday before memorial day
and it's all thanks to this secondary
system which is deeper has more cool air
with it and as it sweeps through it's
really going to help cool temperatures
down lots of fire weather warnings
reaching from southern nevada all the
way back through the four corners in
effect for our area today and again
tomorrow as we're looking at very dry
gusty conditions very dangerous for any
fire that would break out it would be
very tough to get it under control 101
today as i said and we'll slide
temperatures sliding to the mid 90s
saturday upper 80s barely hanging on
close to 90 degrees for sunday and then
those very mild low 80s for memorial day
that's a cool memorial day for us here
in southern nevada 87 back on tuesday
and then there come those triple digits
again by the end of the week